hallo
ihr fragt euch wahrscheinlich hey warum
ist der spyder aus
es fragt sich niemand der noch ganz kurz
für euch die info das ding ist nicht
kaputt weil es mir beim putzen runter
auf meinen fuß gefallen ist und jetzt
irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig
funktioniert nähen
wir uns heute versammelte denn ich
reagiere auf meine instagram die ems das
haben sich sehr viele von euch gewünscht
meine lieben freunde von herrn will ich
sagen fangen wir gar mit einer antwort
auf meine story und zwei ich hoffe die
drei stunden gehen nie um
ja
da habe ich mein heutiges video
angekündigt und er will ist das t shirt
hat man auch bügeln können deine fresse
hat man auch halten können
sein enger freundlicher kontakt zur
community es mir einfach extrem wichtig
man lukas macht auch eine trigger
warnung bitte wenn du dein face film
macht auch selber eine trigger bahn
schlagfertig
auch ganz wichtig weil luca wie geht es
dir ich habe eine frage wie kann man
bilder oder videos hochladen ich habe
erst heute angefangen mit instagram es
wäre sehr lieb wenn du mir diese frage
beantworten könntest liebe grüße philipp
und dann einen tag später schicken um 25
fragezeichen philipp
ich glaube du bist das perfekte beispiel
für die luchse wir wissen alle nicht wie
irgendwas funktioniert von daher
herzlich willkommen ich hoffe du bist
und aufräumen kann hier auch ein
perfektes beispiel für die luchse hier
schreibt nämlich jemand am freitag tag 1
wohnung kann nicht antwortet dann hat es
am samstag und sonntag verpackt und
heute am montag schreibt er okay auch
wenn übrigens ich heiße david er heißt
david steht auf seinem profil was er
kann nicht mehr seinen eigenen namen
schreiben auch dich da wird heißt ich
herzlich willkommen in der luke frisch
verliebt ist auch schon aber nicht von
meinem kanal hey mann das leben ist so
kompliziert also jetzt wirklich wirklich
ja auch dich begrüße ich in der luke
passt ja auch perfekt rein vom
intelligenzquotienten geschickt wenn
jemand am 9
dezember 2018 ein herz dann hat er mir
irgendwie zwei jahre gar nichts
geschrieben und dann am freitag hey du
idiot
am samstag hey du idiot am samstagabend
hey du idiot und dann heute nacht um 22
hey du idiot und dann heute mittag um 2
uhr auch nochmal hey du idiot also
man so verbittert ist dass man mir das
nachts um halb drei schreibt und dann
wieder am nächsten tag um 14 uhr dann
ist man verbitterter als zart
bitterschokolade
humor wird ganz groß geschrieben
ihr lernt hier richtig was
wenn ihr
gold
schlagfertigkeit
soll ich das schon wieder vergessen
wenn bruder
mein judo war
wie nennt man die flug airline mit der
bahn nur karotten fliegen dürfen
robert
wegen repair
spontan
zeep wird ganz groß geschrieben auf
diesem kanal klick und dem video auf
abonnieren oder ärmel rutschen runter
beim händewaschen domain luca du stinkst
man muss auch mit hate umgehen können
es ist wichtig
das man sowas nicht nah an sich ran
lässt
bei mir ist es zum glück durch bekommen
relativ wenig hey bist haßloch
mich lässt das kalt
es ist auch wenn ihr youtuber werden
wollt wichtig dass sie auf einer ebene
mit eurer community seite
nicht nur mental
sondern auch mental
der zahnpflege
luca du bist ein absoluter lauch ja
jetzt kann man dann auch mal irgendwie
aussicht ist schöner als du was ja auch
nicht schwer ist
egoismus
ein thema was was oft verschwiegen als
die schnauze kleinen pässe um deinen
bart zu entfernen braucht man keine
rasierer eine pinzette reicht völlig aus
einfach mensch bleiben in solchen
zion
denkt euch einfach immer daran was wer
bin ich hier
jetzt hier sitzen würde
wer der jetzt stolz auf meine reaktion
ja
ich las sowas nicht an mich ran
meine nachricht öffnest du nicht du bist
sehr sehr hundebisse
einfach dann einen solchen momenten auch
überlegen haye
da sitzen war schwer und er guckt
jetzt war meine nachrichten nicht lesen
aber irgendwie bist du komisch eine
story mag dich trotzdem h gehen wir
zusammen zu mcdonald's auf deinen
nackten mit leuten die einen lachenden
katze smiley benutzen will ich nirgendwo
hingehen ich weiß dass du mit sandra
zusammen bist also gehe mit ihr unter
die dusche hier hat mir eine person an
weihnachten einfach geschrieben schreibt
dennoch diese leute jetzt früher in den
wozzeck status drin hatten und das war
damals auch noch so dass man in seinem
war damals noch so dass man nicht seine
chats untereinander gesehen hat mit
einer vorschau von der nach richtige
person geschrieben hat oder die man
selbst selbst geschrieben hat neda stand
immer der whatsapp status das können nur
die waren
ich glaube ich wäre top 1 kanal den
youtube in diesem jahr noch sperren
könnte
doch mal sachen draußen alter nicht nur
zocken ich werde krank
also wenn ich hier so aus dem fenster
gucken
dann geht das erst mal gar nicht weil er
seinen roller form aber es sind real tor
gerade - 7000 grad draußen wir haben in
hamburg bald eine ausgangssperre ich
darf mich mit keiner person treffen
wegen corona es hat nichts offen draußen
ich wirklich direkt erkälten also
er kam genau
ihr schreibt mir eine person ein
silvester hallo was geht dann eine woche
später hallo was geht nichts kann ich
verstehen
also antwortet sich quasi selbst und
dann noch mal ein paar tage später hallo
was geht was geht oder was soll gehen
ich nicht also ich sitz grad warm up
shows in der nächsten instanz dem die
ich bekommen habe hat mir jemand auf
meine story von gestern abend
geantwortet denn sandra hat sich
sommersprossen ins gesicht gemalt und
ist einfach aus als hätte jemand durch
ein spaghetti 7 ins gesicht gekickt das
habe ich die post und hat geantwortet
hahaha ich war das
warum
seid ihr so hat mich jemand auf eine
story aufmerksam gemacht die anscheinend
von mir geklaut wurde ich weiß nicht wie
man eine story clown soll aber dass
videos auf jeden fall verborgen weil es
ein privates konto ist und da muss ich
mal ganz kurz intervenieren
wenn man interview macht mir das
definitiv anders als brustschwimmen luca
ganz kurze ansage an alle unter euch die
es benötigt halten ihren freunden auf
instagram beiträge fotos videos die
zentren von einem privaten account sind
denkst du es interessiert mich jetzt so
sehr dass ich darauf folgen klick ich
weil man sich ja nicht mal eine vorschau
ich weiß nicht mal was mich da erwartet
das einzige was ich sagen kann ist wenn
ihr hier
ihr folgt entweder auf youtube oder auf
auf instagram
dann könnte nämlich gar nichts erwarten
[Musik]
im 1